[Music]
this is the us-made Abrams one of the
three types of western style tanks that
Ukraine is expecting from its allies and
this is the t-72 the Soviet era tank
that's been used most frequently in the
war so far
as the Wall Street Journal first
reported the U.S and its allies have
agreed to send tanks to Ukraine ahead of
more intense fighting in the spring
Abrams and german-made leopards are
being sent to Kiev in addition to
uk-made Challenger twos
so as Ukraine says getting a significant
number of those weapons would be a game
changer here's how heavy vehicles from
the West match up to Russia's older but
much larger tank Fleet
first let's look at why Ukraine argues
that tanks are so important so the front
lines of this war have been pretty
static in the last few months a lot of
the fighting has been taking place along
these vast planes and on small hills and
that's the kind of terrain and Landscape
that allows the big military vehicles to
operate pretty efficiently
the two main types of armored vehicles
being used in Ukraine right now are main
battle tanks and infantry fighting
Vehicles also known as ifvs tanks have
heavy armor big guns and caterpillar
treads when tanks face each other on the
battlefield military experts say they
typically look for a weak point along
the front line to try and break through
and Destroy other heavy vehicles ifvs on
the other hand are smaller and lighter
they have some of the characteristics of
Tanks but their main purpose is
transporting infantry safely around the
battlefield while also providing fire
support with their smaller weapons
prior to the invasion Ukraine had
significantly fewer armored fighting
Vehicles than Russia but now kiev's NATO
allies are sending more modern military
vehicles to Ukraine today I'm announcing
that the United States will be sending
31 Abram tanks to Ukraine the equivalent
of one Ukrainian battalion
so how will Western tanks help Ukrainian
forces well for tanks the most important
factor is survivability
weapons experts measure this by
estimating how resistant the vehicles
are to anti-tank weapons like the
us-made javelin or the Russian Corner as
well as armor-piercing rounds fired by
other tanks
analysts say the Challenger 2 and Abrams
Tanks which were both used in the Iraq
War are some of the most protected tanks
in the world
that's because they both have a
composite armor called chobam it uses a
combination of Steel Ceramics and other
materials to create particularly
resistant plates military analysts say
this protection gives them A major
advantage over the t-72 over 500 of
which have been destroyed so far in the
Ukraine war german-made leopard tanks
don't use that same armor technology but
have other similar characteristics to
the Abrams and challenger 2. all three
types of advanced computer systems and
modern 120 millimeter guns military
analysts say they're less vulnerable
than the gun on the t-72 which hold this
ammunition at the bottom of the turret
on the ground the tanks which are
expensive and fewer number will also get
some extra support other armored
vehicles are just as important and the
US has also promised to deliver 50 M2
Bradley Fighting vehicles in Ukraine the
Bradley has a number of modern
advantages including thermal imaging
quicker reload times and an armor that's
believed to be more resistant than the
Russian equivalents that includes the
Soviet era bump 2 which have been
commonly used in the war so far hundreds
of these vehicles have been destroyed in
Ukraine according to the military
tracking site oryx while the US says
only three Bradleys were lost in the
Iraq War
but once Ukraine's forces get new tanks
using them effectively won't be easy
many of these systems use different
ammunition and require their own
maintenance schedules it's still going
to take a few months to set up the
supply chains the fuel lines and the
train Crews needed for the Ukraine to
take advantage of these weapons and the
few amounts that have been promised so
far make it unlikely that it's going to
impact the war anytime soon Battlefield
conditions could also reduce their
effectiveness the Western systems are
heavier meaning that they can be more
limited when in boggy areas and Crossing
Bridges
although its Fleet is aging and
diminished Moscow has hundreds more
tanks in storage centers
Ukraine on the other hand says it needs
300 tanks to push back Russian forces
many more than the initial shipments
expected from the West